hundreds of Valley High School students
learning not from books but from
Trailblazers today eight news now's
Brian will spoke to students about the
impact the day had on them
giving us the opportunities they didn't
have so are a road to where they at is
easier for us so we can just learn from
them that's what educators are hoping
students take away from this leadership
Workshop hosted at Canyon Springs High
School in North Las Vegas on Friday Dr
West Hall with the young men of color
leadership initiative says he hopes
students walk away not afraid to ask the
world for what they want they learned
networking they learned how to ask they
learned some of the traits if you watch
they they stood around and talked with
the mayor and the mayor was given like
right in real time things you should do
the panel was full of many local
Pioneers including the first
African-American mayor of North Las
Vegas and the first African-American
president of UNLV the vice president of
the Raiders a county commissioner and a
representative from Caesar's
entertainment today was a moment for our
students that they saw real people in
power positions running Las Vegas
approachable and in proximity to them
that they could believe
that they could reach for and touch one
of them did say like if you're not going
to get to the end you have to start so
like that came up to my mind like oh
you're not going to keep on saying like
oh I can't do this or I can't do that
but you just have to keep on moving
forward to get to
the way I was just expecting some brief
questions here and there not definitely
not something of the size of this
college I got a lot more than I thought
I would get out of here
today's event was part of the leaders of
the future empowerment series put on in
part by UNLV and CCSD